[Music]
breaking news this thursday night
another change to the guidelines about
the astrazeneca vaccine
the latest advice adding to anxiety and
confusion
while pressure builds to relax travel
restrictions we need a safe and
science-based re-opening
suspected killer on the loose the
manhunt in manitoba
underway this hour murder mystery nbc
this case is one of the most atypical
strange a woman's death and the
questions about a secretive company
and its activities in canada and
attention
shoppers why some stores are removing
all cashiers and going
all self-checkout
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news about the
astrazeneca vaccine
advice about it has evolved ever since
it was approved for use in canada
and today it changed yet again the
national advisory committee on
immunization now recommends provinces
stop administering the astrazeneca
vaccine to those who were waiting to get
a second dose of it
instead canada's public health officer
says an mrna vaccine either pfizer or
moderna is the preferred second dose
based on emerging evidence of a
potentially better
immune response but it's really the
immunogenicity that immune response
after that makes those schedule that's
resulted in nasty updating this
recommendation
because the the all the
accumulated study essentially suggests
that that immune response
is a better response
and of course we will continue to
monitor this
nasty does say though those who got two
doses are protected it also says there's
new evidence of
vaccine-induced blood clots or vit after
a second dose of astrazeneca it says
the likelihood of developing the
condition after getting the second shot
has increased over time
with current estimates of approximately
one per six hundred thousand people
vaccinated
it's now up to the provinces to take
nasi's advice and change their plans
for astrazeneca second doses another big
story that depends on vaccines is the
lifting of travel restrictions
canada's premiers are meeting with the
prime minister about that tonight
as vaccines ramp up rules about
international travel including crossing
the border to the u.s
are still stuck in neutral it's no
surprise there's a need for a plan to
get back to normal
two-thirds of canadians live within 100
kilometers of the u.s border
the u.s is our biggest trading partner
and pre-covet it was the most popular
tourist destination for canadians
freedom is tied to vaccinations and
right now about 16 percent of canadians
have had both doses and are fully
protected
as that number rises so does the
pressure to have a plan
to loosen restrictions david aiken is
with me from ottawa david this meeting
with the premier's just wrapped up and i
guess sources say it was productive
it was productive but you know it's
interesting donna because at times
during this pandemic some premiers have
been howling of course for ottawa to
tighten those border restrictions well i
can tell you the mood has certainly
changed and so this meeting wrapped up
and the premiers and the pm in fact did
talk about easing border restrictions
and that was the main item on tonight's
agenda
the trudeau government though wants the
provinces to lead the way
so the premiers at today's meeting are
looking at the very least
to provide some consensus and clarity to
the federal government
on things like vaccination certificates
and timelines to ease restrictions
premier ford is working this week with
federal provincial and territorial
leaders to make sure that
we have a consistent approach in how
we reopen the border safely some
premiers have requests
specific to their region alberta premier
jason kenney for example
wants to reopen the edmonton airport to
international travel
it has been closed to out-of-country
flights for 15 months and
that closure has cost the edmonton
economy more than one
billion dollars this is why it's such an
urgent need to make sure that we want to
understand
what the rules will be to reopen but two
also make sure that we're set
uh when that does come that we're set to
go and and really get into the recovery
phase
quickly the pressure to ease travel
restrictions is not just coming from
premiers
there are mps in trudeau's own caucus
itching for the government to act
on the advice of a federal panel of
experts which has said
travel restrictions can now safely be
eased
we all need to raise our voices and say
we need a safe and science-based
reopening
americans too are getting impatient with
canada would allow my buffalo neighbors
to take a nine hour flight to paris
france
but they can't take a 90-minute drive to
paris ontario
now donna you mentioned the meeting was
productive that's what i heard as well
some premier's office is saying it was
uneventful which is also
code for productive now the meeting
tonight went
long it was only scheduled for an hour
and they took
two and sure enough as i mentioned
details on borders was the top topic but
the meeting ended with more questions
really than answers
bc's premier john horgan for example
he's pressing for details on
opening his province to cruise ships but
again no answer yet on that or
when fully vaccinating canadians will be
able to return
without full quarantine that's still to
come donna
all right david aiken in ottawa thanks a
manhunt is underway tonight near the
manitoba ontario border for a man
suspected of murder
the rcmp say eric wildman is considered
armed and dangerous
he's described as six foot two around
170 pounds with blue eyes
he was spotted driving a chevy equinox
near white mouth manitoba
the search is now focused on the white
shell area a region popular with campers
and cottagers
marnie blunt is in the region tonight
tracking developments
a quiet scene on the streets of white
mouth manitoba
the area the last known sighting of eric
wildman
a 34 year old at the center of an rcmp
manhunt
and it's leaving the community on edge
some were pretty concerned some said
before they went to work this morning
they
actually went and locked all their
buildings and that so there is a little
bit of that fear factor that's going on
wildman is a suspect in the death of
clifford joseph
the two were neighbors in a community
northeast of winnipeg
joseph's body has not yet been found but
rcmp are calling it a homicide
police believe wildman is driving a 2020
gray chevy equinox
officers also say they found police
tactical gear in his truck
as well as clothing that resembled a
police uniform
they say he is armed and dangerous
east of winnipeg near the ontario border
residents in the community of west hawk
say there's been a heavy police presence
there's like a lot of
police in rcmp driving by i've noticed
like every few minutes burnett says it
has some feeling uneasy
they're kind of scared especially
because there's a lot of families here
so they've got kids to take care of
police say they're doing everything they
can to find the suspect
but the search is complex it's you know
a provincial park
there's lots of trails and bushes and
roads and
you name it so it's a bit of a challenge
ontario provincial police jess reopened
the border one day ago after was closed
for more than a month due to covenanting
restrictions
the rcmp says it's working with the opp
on the case
donna marnie blunt in west hawk lake
manitoba thanks
in ottawa the defense minister is facing
an all-out attack from the opposition
harjit sajan is the target of a house of
commons vote condemning his handling of
some major files
involving allegations of sexual
misconduct in the military
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson explains what is underway
mercedes donna it's been a tough week
for the defense minister
the motion comes amid growing calls for
sagin to either resign
or be fired after more questions about
his leadership emerged
following the now notorious golf game
between military brass and former
defense chief
john vance who is under police
investigation for sexual misconduct
while the opposition can't force sagin
out they can
publicly scold him and that's what's
expected to happen tonight in the house
of commons
the opposition is taking aim at the
minister's handling
of the sexual misconduct crisis that has
engulfed the canadian forces
it also criticizes sajin's handling of
the government's battle with vice
admiral mark norman
conservative leader aaron o'toole led
the charge in question period
how possibly can the women in the
canadian armed forces
have any faith in this minister to do
his job after he failed them so badly
there is clearly a toxic culture in our
armed forces
and that must change and i do want to
say
our government has full confidence in
our minister of national defense
the vote to centre sagin is expected to
pass later tonight
with the ndp and bloc both supporting it
but it won't carry any formal
consequences
aside from the public shaming in the
meantime
sajin is again apologizing and vowing to
do better
i also feel the pain of our members and
i will do my darnedest
and best always for the sake of the
canadian armed forces until we get an
environment that's inclusive meanwhile
time is running out for the defense
committee to produce its report on
military sexual misconduct
amongst the senior ranks that committee
shut down its hearings amid
acrimonious debate in april that saw the
liberals insisting the time was needed
to produce a report
while the conservatives and ndp wanted
to hear from more witnesses
but now with two meetings left and lots
of filibustering
that report may never see the light of
day on thursday the status of women
committee released its report into
military sexual misconduct
it makes 21 recommendations pressing the
government
to act quickly but for now there are
questions about whether the minister
is up to the job of seeing those changes
through
donna mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks
prime minister justin trudeau has named
a nominee to join canada's supreme court
justice mahmoud jamal is an expert in
constitutional law and was a litigator
before becoming
an ontario court of appeal judge in
2019. he taught at mcgill in osgood hall
law schools and is fully bilingual
in a statement the prime minister says
justice jamal with his exceptional legal
and academic experience and dedication
to serving others
will be a valuable asset to our
country's highest court
born in kenya to a family originally
from india he is
poised to be the first person of color
on the supreme court of canada
coming up one of the strangest cases bc
police say
they have ever investigated
one year ago today police say a chinese
woman in surrey bc was brutally beaten
to death
investigators say it is one of the
strangest cases they've ever seen
their investigation has revealed the
victim worked for a self-improvement
organization
as jeff semple reports the case is
raising questions about the secretive
company
and its activities in canada
joe clementi doesn't typically see many
people on his drive to work
he lives on bc's secluded salt spring
island
between vancouver and victoria it is
kind of like a little sleepy hollow
but one afternoon in 2018 clementi's
commute
took a strange turn he spotted dozens of
asian men and women marching down this
rural road
in military uniforms i actually couldn't
believe it and i'm glad
i had my camera on salt spring island
clementi uploaded this video to his
youtube channel where he typically posts
videos of his garden
and around this time last year the
footage caught the attention
of the rcmp this case
has to rank as one of the most
typical strange
just down the road from where the video
was recorded is this
seaside resort owned by a company called
create abundance also known as golden
touch
the so-called self-improvement
organization
claims to promote spiritual and
financial prosperity
its leaders own several high-end
properties in bc
including this one in surrey and on june
17th
last year it became a crime scene
after one of golden touch's employees
was murdered
her injuries were so extensive there was
a comment at the beginning of the
investigation whether
you know was she hit by a car the victim
beau fan had moved to bc from china in
2019
and helped to organize company events
police say the 41 year old was brutally
beaten
found clinging to life not far from the
clubhouse
where golden touch had just hosted a
party
the company which started in china set
up shop
in canada around 2014. chinese
authorities say the organization was
previously linked to dozens of pyramid
schemes in china
and have likened it to a cult social
media posts show its members attending
spiritual seminars and classes in bc
some of which reportedly cost tens of
thousands of dollars to attend
members also appear in military uniforms
posing with what appear to be restricted
even prohibited firearms it is not
acceptable
in canada in 2021 for groups to organize
themselves in camouflage outfits
with weapons prohibited or not trying to
operate in secret
no one from golden touch has responded
to numerous
interview requests and police say they
found no evidence to implicate the
organization
in fans murder but investigators believe
that link
is important jeff semple global news
toronto
for more on this you can listen to
global's new podcast
china rising the episode on golden touch
will be available on apple podcast
spotify amazon music or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
a digital media outlet has fully
retracted its story alleging premier
jason kenney held private dinners inside
a restaurant and a private residence in
alberta while restrictions were in place
it is also apologized to the premier and
ministers jason nixon and tyler chandra
last week the premier denied the
allegations and sent a cease and desist
letter
plus threatened legal action
still ahead a first of its kind study on
wales in norway
china has launched the first of several
crews that will help build its first
full-fledged space station three
astronauts took off on this spacecraft
towards the construction
site they will live and work on it for
three months that will be the longest
day in low orbit of any chinese national
this is the third of 11 missions needed
to finish the station's construction
which began
in april canadian scientists are among
dozens around the world urging norway to
halt a research project
involving minke whales norwegian and
american researchers plan on capturing
the whales to conduct experiments over
how they perceive sound as crystal
gomencing explains their sphere will
cause
too much harm large nets are visible in
the ocean near lofoten
part of an elaborate trap erected by
norwegian and american researchers
to capture minke whales so they can test
their hearing
when we first heard about this couple of
months ago we thought it was a joke to
be honest
because it's a very very unusual setup
to put it mildly when a whale is
captured it'll be funneled into a large
holding tank
from there researchers will secure it
between two rafts
insert electrodes under the skin and
start testing to see what sounds it can
hear
and at what frequency i mean really we
know noise is a problem
lindy wildguard has a background in
citation biology and has been studying
underwater noise impacts for 30 years
we know it even affects ecosystem
services
how about we just quiet the noise how
about that noise from seismic testing in
the oil and gas sector as well as navy
sonar tests
are well documented problems the u.s
navy
is one of the main funders of this
research project
it's being opposed by more than 50
scientists and veterinarians
in a letter to the prime minister of
norway the group expressed
deep concerns with the auditory
experiments saying it could lead to
considerable suffering for the whales
and they want it stopped
those involved with the research say
they are aware of the letter
despite the objection raised they say
many scientists
are in support of this research the
primary investigator peter kavansheim
says that this sort of data specific to
baleen whales
including minkes is needed in order to
protect them
the president of the canadian marine
environment protection society calls the
testing
invasive it's hard to have any hope
doing what you do when you see us moving
backwards
the norwegian food safety authority
approved the acoustic testing
government officials tell global news
media will eventually be allowed on the
site
but having too many people around will
be stressful for the whales
crystal gamansen global news london
unexpected item in the bagging area next
why stores are shifting to
self-checkouts only
and rafael nadal and naomi osaka
announced they won't be competing at
wimbledon
the men's world number three says he is
also pulling out of next month's tokyo
olympics
in a tweet the 35 year old spaniard says
he made the decision after
listening to his body and says the goal
is to prolong his career
and women's world number two naomi osaka
who's been battling depression and
anxiety
will also skip wimbledon a statement
from osaka's team reveals she is taking
some personal
time with friends and family but will be
ready to play in front of her home fans
at the tokyo olympics while the world
seems to be split into two camps those
who head for the self-checkout lines and
those who
can't stand their commands especially
please
wait for assistance increasingly you may
not have any choice
because as ross lord reports some stores
are converting
to self-checkout only lining up for the
cashier could soon be a thing of the
past
at least the living breathing version
the lineup where you stand in line
patiently sometimes saying why can't
they speed up the line and why am i in
the line for 10 minutes
that experience will disappear the shift
is underway
at amazon's u.s grocery stores shoppers
barely need to break stride
everything they select is compiled in a
virtual shopping cart
their accounts are then billed on the
way out canadian retailers are also
shifting to automation
walmart canada says a handful of its
stores across the country will switch to
self-checkout this summer
as part of a pilot program which
suggests it could be the start of
something much bigger
more canadians than ever it seems are
ready yeah i like automated
that's my fave oh it's faster
you know you're in you're out quickly
polling suggests the pandemic and the
emphasis on avoiding contact with others
has made automated shopping more
attractive i think people are starting
to really see
their experience a little bit
differently and will actually value the
self-checkout option a little bit more
in fact we're singing in our numbers a
survey of 10
000 consumers conducted last month shows
53 percent of canadian grocery shoppers
intend to use self-checkouts regularly
in coming months
for younger shoppers gen zeds and
millennials the numbers are even higher
topping 60 percent tilting the balance
in favor of automation
there are still plenty of holdouts like
looking up product codes and things like
that
becomes a bit of a hassle so i do lean a
little bit more towards the
going to an actual cashier job loss is
another concern
although walmart canada says during the
pilot program
its self-checkout area will be staffed
to help customers figure it out
so who wins in the end i think everyone
can win
including consumers if the technology
delivers
in shopping as in society at large it
seems the only thing permanent these
days
is change ross lord global news
and that's global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada
is this it's a rope tornado that touched
down near fisk saskatchewan this week
most tornadoes start and end as a type
of rope tornado but this one maintained
that signature skinny shape throughout
and it's caught the attention of storm
chasers around the world
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye-bye
you